merci cher jean pierre en fait la santé
n'est pas une compétence obligatoire des
régions malgré tout on voit bien dans
les projets et les programmes de nos
candidats qu'ils y attachent une grande
importance tout simplement parce que
c'est une préoccupation majeure de nos
compatriotes alors je me suis amusé à
regarder quelles étaient les
propositions nos candidats en la matière
c'était assez rassurant puisque revient
sans arrêt l'idée de lutter contre les
déserts médicaux vous savez qu'il ya à
peu près deux millions de personnes en
france qui se trouvent confrontés à
cette difficulté et nos candidats
clairement envie de soutenir ce qu'on
appelle les maisons pluridisciplinaires
de santé qui n'ont pas été inventés par
les socialistes ni les maisons de santé
d'ailleurs mais par la majorité
précédente et la ministre des affaires
sociales que je fréquente assidûment à
l'assemblée nationale ce que je fais
partie de la commission des affaires
sociales a tendance à oublier parfois
que c'est pas son idée que ça a été
inventé avant elle donc toutes nos
candidats souhaitent en effet soutenir
dans nos régions la création ou la
rénovation de ces maisons plus
disciplinaire de santé on a des
candidats qui vont plus loin qu'ils ont
envie en fait d'inciter les jeunes
médecins à aller s'installer là où il ya
des déserts médicaux c'est vrai qu'on a
des débats est ce qu'il faut obliger les
médecins à s'installer dans nos régions
là où il ya des déficits ou est ce qu'il
faut les inciter et on arrive toujours
en discutant avec eux à la même idée
qu'il faut plutôt les inciter donc on a
des candidats je pense en particulier à
laurent wauquiez en région rhône alpes
qui propose de verser une bourse aux
étudiants moyennant bien évidemment
l'engagement de s'installer et de rester
sur les territoires régionaux et bien
évidemment c'est une idée qui est retenu
par notre candidat marc le fur en
bretagne et de nombreuses autres
certains veulent aller aussi plus loin
dans la prévention
et là je parle aussi sous le contrôle de
marque on et plusieurs à habiter dans
des régions très industrielle ou les
troubles musculo squelettiques des
personnes qui travaillent dans
l'industrie industrie pour laquelle on a
parfois du mal à recruter ou à la lutte
contre les troubles
musculo-squelettiques est aussi une
vraie nécessité et donc dans plusieurs
programmes de nos candidats aux
régionales il y à cette volonté
d'adresser un message fort aux ouvriers
et employés de l'industrie pour dire
qu'on prend en compte ses difficultés de
santé dans l'entreprise on souhaite
également développer la télémédecine
olivier chartier nous parlera tout à
l'heure du très haut débit vous savez
que c'est quelque chose qui est très
important sur nos territoires moi je
suis élu en ille et vilaine dans un
territoire où on met le paquet sur la
télémédecine j'y crois beaucoup c'est le
moyen pour faire venir la médecine au
plus près des personnes et non pas de
les emmener tout en ville et dans les
grandes villes donc je pense qu'il ya un
gros travail à faire dans ce domaine là
mais pour ça il faut du très haut débit
est en effet les socialistes dans le
domaine ont plutôt pris du retard ce qui
est important aussi pour nos candidats
c'est d'appeler à l'initiative vous
savez que les socialistes ont tendance à
vous donner l'idée du bonheur à votre
place et a multiplié ce qu'on appelle
les appels à projets les appels à
projets il faut rentrer dans des cases
plusieurs d'entre vous on en parlait ce
matin c'est très compliqué faut remplir
des gros dossiers et faut absolument
coché toutes les cases pour pouvoir
bénéficier de financements ce qu'on
souhaite nous dans nos régions c'est
qu'au contraire ça parte du terrain et
qui d appel à initiatives et donc dans
le domaine de la santé dans l'eau même
des affaires sociales que ce soit plutôt
la région qui accompagnent les bonnes
initiatives et les bonnes pratiques sur
le territoire plutôt que ce soit le
président d'une région en l'occurrence
pour le moment socialiste qui impose une
idée les bonnes idées les bonnes
initiatives elles sont sur le terrain il
faut les encourager voilà ce que je
pouvais dire dans le domaine de la santé
pour faire bref sachez que là aussi
c'est ce que disait philippe richert
tout à l'heure quand il ya une volonté
il ya un chemin moi je pense qu'en
matière sociale en matière de santé
encore une fois même si c'est pas direct
pendant la compétence des régions il ya
une attente de nos compatriotes est la
meilleure preuve c'est que dans vos
programmes les uns et les autres vous
l'avez intégré